if you search what I in a day on YouTube
some of the top performing videos of all
time are those by Victoria's Secret
models
shocker I know these angels are
considered some of the world's most
beautiful women of all time who managed
to maintain a flat stomach long lean
legs and those perky voluptuous breasts
let's be real most of us cannot relate
especially those of us who pumped and
breastfed two little hungry Gremlins for
two years of Our Lives
going down
so today I aim to do this seemingly
impossible follow the diet of a
supermodel but like make it relatable
witchcraft maybe hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video I'll be eating like
model content creator and new mom Romy
stride but as usual I'll be dressing up
Abby style and turning into hunger
crushing combos that I actually want to
eat a quick disclaimer that this diet
was compiled from a bunch of primary
sources that I found on YouTube but we
actually don't know if this is how Romy
eats every single day not that it
matters because I will only be using
these alleged meals as a template for
teaching gentle nutrition and for
inspiring what I decide to make for
myself this is just what I ate on a
random day and it's not meant to be
copied or recommended as how you should
eat so as always speak to registered
dietitian about your unique needs we are
officially in the holiday season which
means a slightly overwhelming social
calendar over here I mean between the
holiday parties and my 35th birthday in
December I will probably be enjoying my
fair share of adult bevies this month
just saying but I am no spring chicken
so as much as I love my Pinot Grigio I'm
admittedly pretty sensitive to alcohol
so sometimes even one glass of wine can
make me feel off the next day so I was
totally geeking out when I got sent this
zbiotics pre-alcohol probiotic drink
like just in time for the holidays I
mean it's not often that I get really
excited about a new food or supplement
technology but when I try this for going
out and having a few little drinky
drinks it totally blew my mind this is
the world's first genetically engineered
probiotic that's been scientifically
designed to break down the byproduct of
alcohol acetyl aldehyde that's
responsible for those not so fun
mornings the way it works is you drink a
bottle of zebiotics before you have an
alcoholic drink and the probiotic
produces a unique enzyme like the one
your liver naturally uses to break down
the byproduct responsible for that not
so fun morning
it actually worked
this is absolutely not an invitation to
binge drink I mean alcohol is still not
a healthy food and should always be
treated as a substance to be enjoyed in
moderation we all know that over
consumption can lead to poor sleep
digestive distress liver damage and
probably a lot of bad decisions but if
it means I can show up to the Tuesday
night holiday party have a modest glass
of wine and still wake up to screaming
kids at 5am and work a full day without
missing a beat I am here for it I cannot
stress enough how impressed I was with
this product I literally just bought an
entire case and I'm going to be giving
them out to friends at my birthday party
because that's how excited I am about
this it's like an adult loot bag but you
get it before the party starts so if you
want to give zebiotics a try check out
my link in the description and use my
promo code Abby sharp to get 15 percent
off of your first order they also offer
a full money back guaranteed if you're
not satisfied with your purchase but
honestly I don't know how you cannot be
it's pretty amazing all right back to
the video okay so Hallelujah guys I
managed to find a video of a Victoria's
Secret model after she became a mom
hoping that like maybe I would find it
somewhat relatable and doable like most
of these Wellness creators are doing
like 12-step beverage rituals in the
morning and your girl just don't have
time for that in my experience
motherhood really can force people into
more like extremist like Fringe Wellness
communities or it can like soften
pre-existing obsessions around food and
wellness just because you've already got
so many balls that you're trying to
juggle and you just find that trying to
control food or your health in such an
extreme way just no longer is a priority
or serves you I definitely fall into the
latter group and I'm really hoping that
Romy does too because yeah even even if
we would love to I would say most moms
don't have time to put together a
perfectly styled smoothie Bowl every
morning so
so let's get into it Romy what's for
breakfast before my workout I'll just
have a coffee usually I was the one to
have breakfast first thing in the
morning since I do only like a 30 minute
workout where I'm not doing a lot of
cardio but just like simple exercises I
think I'll be fine with the coffee and
making my Burkey after this is great I
love this because this is pretty much
what I've been doing most days of the
week
um just because it's what's convenient
to me and it fits into my family's
schedule but this is usually around the
time when all the holistic nutritionists
just like come out of the woodwork and
say oh no no no no no no no no you can
never drink coffee on an empty stomach
first thing in the morning Abby can you
explain so a lot of influencers insist
that you shouldn't drink coffee on an
empty stomach in the morning because it
allegedly raises your cortisol at a
point in the day when cortisol is
naturally high and this is theoretically
true but in real life it's actually not
a huge deal some studies just that
caffeine can increase cortisol levels
both at rest and during periods of
stress but other research has found no
increase in cortisol levels at all and
this individual variation likely has to
do with one's sensitivity to stress
anxiety high blood pressure and most
importantly their tolerance to caffeine
here's the really important piece of
information that Wellness influencers
don't tell you the impact of caffeine on
cortisol levels seems to diminish with
regular caffeine consumption in other
words if you regularly drink coffee
within like an hour of waking up like
most human freaking beings your body
adapts to this habit and it learns like
nope this isn't a bear coming at me it's
just my usual double double and a bagel
and this significantly Blends the
transient effects on cortisol and that's
another really important keyword here
transient like cortisol levels are
constantly changing throughout the day
so what's natural to see them ebb and
flow now I appreciate that if you have
like a million things working against
you and your anxiety disorder then it's
absolutely worth taking all of these
little tiny steps to maybe reduce stress
and abnormal cortisol levels in the day
but for most people the minute transient
effect of a daily cup of coffee on
cortisol levels are unlikely to cause
long-term harm as for the empty stomach
concern I would say it theoretically
makes sense to have some food with your
coffee if you experience ill effects so
we really don't have any actual evidence
that it would make a big difference so
as always experiment to see what feels
best to you yeah I have literally
noticed no difference whatsoever in my
stress levels because I actually did a
period where I removed caffeine from my
diet just to see if it was going to
improve my sleep and my anxiety it did
not help I do have a sensitive tummy so
I do find that having like drip black
coffee or just having like a splash of
milk in it first thing in the morning
with no food that can sometimes upset my
stomach a little bit but that's why I
pretty much always have have like a
latte which has some milk in it so we've
got some carbohydrates some fats some
protein it's basically like a mini mini
mini mini mini snack and that really
seems to be what feels best to me so
that's what I'm gonna do
it's coffee I swear
all right coffee down I'm gonna go get
ready for a workout
[Music]
I'm not sure what I'll be having for
breakfast usually I have like either
rice cakes with avocado
egg or yogurt or blueberries peanut
butter Goji berries so I think I'll go
for the oven okay so I love this
um this is definitely something that I
would make myself but I am a full fat
yogurt girly through and through
honestly it just tastes miles better and
it has some really important health
benefits as well more and more recent
research seems to be flipping the script
on saturated fats one 22-year study
found that full fat Dairy may actually
be protective against heart disease and
another meta-analysis found that full
fat Dairy was inversely related to
obesity risk it also appears to be more
favorable over low or non-fat for
fertility and insulin resistance
especially in folks with PCOS and since
it provides both satiating protein and
fat for my Hunger crushing combo and
also it's just generally like way more
satisfying I'm a huge believer in
choosing full fat all right we're
starting with some plain painful Fat
Greek yogurts we got fats we got protein
lots of good stuff there
let's do some banana that's not in uh
romy's traditional mix but I like banana
and I've got some ones that are near
their end of their life and I gotta use
it today otherwise I'm gonna be forced
to make banana bread and your girl
doesn't have time to make banana bread
so we got bloops how massive these
blueberries are they're good blueberries
either have to be itty bitty or big
Honkers right there's no in between good
blueberries in my opinion
she likes strawberries
strawberries are not in season here but
I do have these like freeze-dried
strawberries which I'm obsessed with my
kids think they're like literally candy
they're so delicious so sweet so
expensive but you know what they're
really good snack
that's going down
look at those
now these are some of her favorites she
uses goji berries
they're sweet they're better than I
remember
and they add nice color look at that so
some of that you guys know I'm obsessed
with 10 parts can't go wrong
fiber Protein healthy fats all the goods
chia
like that again this is not something
that Romy does but I feel like this bowl
for me for breakfast needs a little bit
more carbs so I love cereal cereal loves
me and I always have a lot of cereal in
my house so this is one of my current
favorites it's called puffins it's a
nice high fiber cereal I'm gonna throw
that on top for some extra carbs extra
fiber and extra Crunch and then she's
also got some nuts so I'm gonna do that
too
lots of healthy fats look at this
it's gonna be like
where's the breakfast and it's assembly
style we love to see it all right let's
recap protein in the yogurt plus of
course all the nuts and seeds tons of
healthy fats hemp Chia uh the pecans
here so much fiber from the fruit and
the cereal I mean it's a beautiful Bowl
it's packed with antioxidants can't go
wrong it's a huge upgrade for my usual
yogurt Bowls in the morning which is
basically you know whatever leftover
spoonfuls are left from my kids snotty
yogurt from the morning doesn't look
like this let's see how she tastes
look at that just like
attaches glue
so good all right I'm going to finish up
here do a little bit of work and I'll
meet you back here at lunch all right so
for lunch it looks like Romy does a
little ordering in which we love because
it means one less thing I have to cook
let's take a look okay lunch has arrived
the little one is awake got the salad
and the chicken avocado sandwich bagel
so I am all about ordering in lunch when
I feel like I can afford it because I
always find that lunch hours like the
hardest time of day to commit to cooking
a meal from scratch so if I don't have
leftovers from the night before I'm
usually just kind of like throwing
together like a real hodgepodge of a
meal
um but it's Friday here while we're
filming and I want to splurge I don't
want to do too much if I don't have to
I'm tired so I'm excited about this and
I also don't think it's very realistic
for people who are watching at home to
see these creators making three
beautifully styled meals a day plus
snacks I mean ain't nobody got time for
that so leftovers hodgepodge assembly
take out that's kind of how I roll for
lunch and if romy's going to order in
I'm definitely going to order it now I
don't live in LA so I don't have as many
like beautiful kind of gourmet lunch
places that make really fancy salads and
stuff like that we have a few but not so
much uh but I'm gonna try to find
something relatively similar and I'm
sure I'll be really satisfying
and I got some extra bagels for the rest
of the weekend so we love a double duty
app like that all right
at our fresh Montreal Bagels
cinnamon
pumpernickel
Sesame excited and then got well this is
supposed to be the salad it looks sad
but maybe there's stuff underneath I'll
show you in a sec
oh yeah okay it's just very strangely
layered I'm gonna have to deconstruct it
for you guys and let's take a look see
this one's I think mine Brody this is
yours
we've got a whole operation here okay
they gave me caesar dressing unusual
choice
but we're gonna work with it all right
so they didn't have chicken and avocado
on a bagel like our girl Romy has
ordered so I just got avocado because I
knew that I had some leftover chicken in
the fridge and this way I'm kind of
saving money because I'm not having to
buy like everything from scratch and
like add six bucks for adding on the
chicken or whatever I got some right
here and we can use that up all right
so let's just layer in some chicken is
going to be a challenging sandwich to
get my little mouth around
okay
but look at that oh
oh oh
the avocado makes it slippery and I feel
like they overdid it on the lettuce
which is making it too
oh
all right I'll just put this here for
now let's try to dig and see what is
undercover in this salad here
such a mystery we got some spinach and
lettuce
cucumber
this is so so strange Tomatoes okay but
guys I literally ordered the avocado
salad I hate to be the [ __ ] that has
to like complain to Uber about these
things but that's disappointing I gotta
judge this up so I'm excited to eat it
I'm gonna show you how I do that let's
fix this mess
I like a little sprinkle sprinkle of
some hemp hearts we got some
sunflower seeds
we got pistachios
more crunch
I found this in my fridge
crispy fried shallots I feel like that's
gonna be delicious yum yes cheese is a
must so
we got some feta here
I'm gonna make up for the Lost avocado
that I paid for and did not get you know
what everyone makes mistakes and I'm
sure it was an honest mistake so service
staff I know work super super hard and
they're overworked okay I don't know if
it's overkill on the bagel but I'm going
for it we're going all in I've got some
Bagel seasoning
why not we've got a little bit of
some that was aggressive two shots of
vodka
white balsamic vinaigrette
see how she goes uh this looks good I
want to try this now look at this
beautiful beautiful salad
we fixed it guys yay all right cheers oh
you got the Montreal smoked meat damn I
wish supermodels liked smoked meat they
are missing out because that is always a
good choice but avocado always slaps
awesome Columbia
tough one to get in the old melt
that's a new technique the dive not the
same like a hot dog it's good though
all right just picked up the kids from
school they are getting hungry so let's
see what we're having for dinner okay so
I've watched a lot of romy's Vlogs and
she's a big fan of like the Buddha bowl
style meals and she also loves a lot of
ingredients that are rich in healthy
fats like salmon avocado and nuts and I
do tend to eat a lot of fats like a lot
of avocado and a lot of salmon because
it keeps me full and I just love the
taste of it we love to see that I mean
fat is such an important part of the
hunger crushing combo Abby tell us more
and I think a lot of folks who grew up
in diet culture still are a bit anxious
about fats because fat contains more
calories than carbs and protein but fats
are inherently satiating and it being
shown to help regulate appetite through
a number of important mechanisms for
example fats can slow gastric emptying
which can also benefit our blood sugar
levels while regulating the hormones
responsible for our appetite research
also suggests that combining fat with
fiber has an even greater synergistic
effect on satiety which is why foods
like avocados for example or even like a
Buddha bowl with veggies and fats can be
so inherently filling okay so in this
one video I watched of hers she made
this beautiful looking bowl that had
rice salmon avocado spinach brussels
sprouts pretty much all of my favorite
ingredients so I'm gonna try to
replicate that all right so let's
assemble this bowl we got some spinach
it's gonna go down first just to like
that I got some rice that I cooked and I
actually cooked this in bone broth just
to bump up the protein even more and
also it adds like a lot of really good
flavor let's go grab our salmon all
right this is a generous piece of salmon
I feel like I'll save this little tiny
piece for my kiddos there we go
beaut
some roasted Brussels avocado of course
this one might be over ripe we're gonna
have to see when we get there yeah she's
not feeling so hot oh no wow wow okay I
gotta back up
chunks
avocado
you're so creamy and good
a little more
oh
are you gonna start a counter of all my
my mess making okay all right let's just
clean this up for a minute
my mother taught me to always clean as
you go
which I try to do Mama make you proud
okay we need nuts in this situation
come on let's get
nuts some pistachios are gonna be a
beautiful option I'm gonna add some
gorgeous color and a really nice Crunch
and I just feel like any of these like
rice bowls need some kind of sauce like
almost like a dressing Meats smelling a
little like creamy so I'm not sure what
I'm gonna make a little tahini
a little bit of
greedy mustard I got some lemon here
fish out of seed
and some leaves while we're at it nice
maple syrup
that's that out
[Music]
thin it out
it's good oh salt and pepper always
essential
I add cheese to everything so
feather
okay this is a bowl your girl wants to
eat we have lots of carbs and some Fiber
in our rice plus tons of fiber in all
the vegetables and the nuts and the
avocado healthy fats and the nuts
avocado and salmon protein in the salmon
we've got more healthy fats I just
realized in the tahini I mean whoa this
is a nutrient dense bowl that looks
delicious and I'm sure is going to taste
damn good let's get in there
foreign
makes it rummy take note okay so I went
through like all the recent vlog footage
that I saw from Romy and I didn't see
any kind of evidence of like a bedtime
snack or dessert I always have some kind
of bedtime snack and or dessert
sometimes those things are like the same
thing but I know she's into snacking on
nuts
so I thought we would put together like
a really great sleep supporting nut
trail mix let me show you my fave
all right this couldn't be simpler
that was awkward
don't know why I ate okay anyways
we got popcorn pre-pop popcorn because
again I'm busy and I don't want to
always have to pop it myself so I just
buy it in the bag kill me I've got some
more of my pistachios because I guess
that's the nut of the day here and I'm
feeling it pistachios are delicious with
popcorn and these ones are actually
crazy good they're the sea salt vinegar
one that with popcorn
slaps all right and then my new found
favorite bedtime snack
tart cherries I'm gonna throw those in
there too I don't know how it's going to
work with the salt and vinegar but I am
ready to take the risk I guess let's get
all these in
mmm pretty good sweet salty kind of
buttery vinegary we're hitting all the
marks here folks this is like a gourmet
snack meal and you guys know that I'm
not a great sleeper on a good night so I
always try to have like a really good
hunger crushing combo snack before bed
plus the tart cherries do have some
extra benefits tart cherries have been
cited as a natural sleep remedy for
decades and we actually have some
evidence that consuming tart cherry
juice before bed increases exogenous
melatonin production and enhances our
Sleep Quality now realistically you
would have to consume a ton of actual
Whole Food tart cherries to reach the
clinical dose used in the research but I
certainly don't think that it hurts to
add a few of them to your bedtime snack
honestly this day was totally my style
all the meals were like beautifully
balanced with protein fiber and healthy
fats and they were really delicious as
well so I definitely like looked forward
to eating them not to mention most
importantly they actually felt like
something that I could do and manage on
a regular basis on a busy work week
especially because I got to order
luncheon I don't typically watch any
kind of like Mom Vlog content on YouTube
mainly because I'm just really against
broadcasting images of our kids online
but I would definitely continue to watch
some of uromi's food content for some
easy meal inspiration and on that note
that's all that I have for you guys
today if you enjoyed this video be sure
to give it thumbs up leave me a comment
below on Whose diet you'd like me to try
next subscribe to the channel and I will
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]